[MUSIC PLAYING]
PHIL WEAVER: Good afternoon.
Thanks for coming.
My name is Phil.
I'm here with Casey
and Qasid, and we
want to talk to you about making
accessibility easy on Android.
Thanks.
So first, a bit about
what accessibility does.
And ultimately, a
lot of engineering
ends up being about
assumptions, right?
We find that-- usually
when we find we've made a--
when we made an assumption,
we eventually discover it
when we realize it's not right.
And that happens a lot
with accessibility.
It's really easy to make
assumptions about what people--
particularly people
with disabilities--
can and can't do.
If you meet somebody who
uses a power wheelchair,
you might make an assumption
that they probably
don't play soccer.
And this on the face of it might
sound like a pretty plausible
assumption, but then you haven't
seen my son's power soccer
team.
There was a World Cup of
power wheelchair soccer.
So whatever-- like if you
meet somebody who's blind--
I've heard people who were, for
example, using photo carousels.
And they go, well,
maybe blind people
wouldn't be interested in
keeping track of photos.
Now we now have technology to
let blind people take pictures
of things, and they're
very interested,
it turns out, in sharing
them with people.
And then there's
the simplest one,
which is making the
assumption that somebody
who's not able to move
their mouth can't speak.
But of course, Stephen
Hawking demonstrated
that that assumption is
wrong long, long ago.
And thank goodness he did.
So on Android, we make
a lot of assumptions.
It seems like a
lot of assumptions
are built into our devices.
Take a touchscreen device--
touch screen, you might assume
people can-- all of the users
are able to touch the
device, or that they can all
see what's on the screen.
But of course, that
turns out not to be true.
And so these assumptions, we
have to learn to question them,
otherwise they become obstacles.
And so a lot of what
accessibility really is
is about helping people
with disabilities
overcome obstacles.
And we want to really--
the first thing is
just to make sure
that the obstacles we're
helping them overcome
are the ones inherent in
their disability, not the ones
that we've created by making
additional assumptions
about what they're interested
in, what they're actually
able to do.
So the way Android does
accessibility is really--
it depends on the
entire ecosystem.
So we who work
directly on Android,
we build a lot of
the core of it,
but we really depend
on the entire ecosystem
to make this work.
So the accessibility
framework is
going to handle a lot of
low-level features, things
like magnification.
As a developer, you're not
going to build a magnification
experience into your
app in order to help,
so that if we try to do
that into every single app
on Android, we're going to
end up with just a nightmare
experience.
And also it's something that's
really best handled down,
close to the graphics level.
We want to just magnify things.
Accessibility
developers, people who
work on accessibility
services like TalkBack,
Switch Access, Voice
Access, Select to Speak,
they build these
plug-in services.
And the idea is that
they will generally
have a particular
type of user in mind,
and they'll go
through and really
understand what
those users need,
what their challenges
are, and try to build
something that works for them.
But they, of course, can't
do everything on their own.
They need to get
information from--
like if somebody
is blind, you need
to be able to speak
what's on the screen.
We need to find that out
from the apps, what's
actually going on in the UI.
And that's where we
really need the help
of the entire ecosystem
and all developers.
So as a general model, we
have these plug-in services.
So in this case, Switch Access,
Voice Access, and Braille.
And they're able to query an API
for the accessibility service
to find out.
Like tell me what windows
are on the screen.
Tell me what the views are
inside these windows, what
text is where, what actions
are available on each view.
And then they can
present this to the user
in whatever way they need to.
If the user's not able
to touch the screen,
do you want to activate
this control, that control?
Do you want to
perform this gesture?
And do it on their behalf.
But we really need
the apps to provide
the right semantics to do that.
I'm going to try to make
this as simple as possible.
So just a few things to
kind of keep in mind.
One is just to make sure
that the information
that you're presenting
to all your users
is as visible as possible.
So color contrast or
[INAUDIBLE] contrast
ends up being the most
important single thing
that you can do in
that regard, just
to make sure that
you're not using gray
on slightly lighter gray
to convey information.
And sometimes it can end
up looking kind of cool,
but it becomes very difficult
for some people to use.
A second thing is to just prefer
controls to be big and simple.
It's sometimes a temptation
to cram a whole bunch of stuff
into a small area to get as many
options as possible for users.
And often, just
trying to figure out
what is really
important for your users
can simplify things
for everybody
and also make it
possible for somebody
who perhaps doesn't have
perfect dexterity to use it.
And one thing this week--
we have a general 48 by 48
density independent
pixels as a guideline
that we throw out there just
to have a uniform standard
throughout the ecosystem.
And that can be set with just
a min height, min width thing.
And the other way
is to label stuff.
So if you're conveying
information visually--
particularly what a button--
if there's a button that
just has an icon on it--
just to provide a label.
And these labels should
be concise and precise
so that users who are not
able to see the screen
can find out what they do.
Some times, people
ask, when in my project
should I consider accessibility?
So the three word answer
is early and often.
The slightly longer
answer is in each
of these different
phases of your project,
there's something you can do.
So in design, generally the
things that I just already
mentioned-- of keeping
contrast, control size, labels.
That will get you a
long way if you're
using standard UI patterns.
But the more innovation you're
doing on your user interface,
the further away
you're going to get
from the stuff we built
into the Android framework.
And at that point,
it's really helpful
if you can start thinking
more broadly about how
the full range of users who
are going to use your product.
So the more gesture type
things that you're doing,
you want to make sure that
you're taking into account how
people are going to interact
with that if they perhaps
can't perform that gesture.
During development, we
have a series of APIs.
Qasid's going to
present some of those.
And for testing,
we have a number
of testing tools to help make
sure that as much as possible
we can automate the process
of making sure you're handling
these things correctly.
So I just explained a
whole bunch of stuff
about all the
complexities of users
and all these different
things you can do.
So you could be forgiven
for wondering why we
said making accessibility easy.
So I did say making, not
that we already made.
But in general, what we want is
we really want this to be easy.
I think we want that to be--
we want to make sure
that we're doing that.
And if we're not,
please let us know.
But if you're using standard
components and standard ways,
it really should be
as simple as what
I've already said,
that you should just
be having to label things.
We should-- the questions that
you need to answer should not
be complicated questions
about how is a particular type
of user going to
use your project--
something like, what
does this control do.
But as you evolve in
more non-standard ways,
it is going to get less easy.
But what we want is to make
sure that the incremental work
that you do for accessibility
grows more slowly than the work
you need to do to serve
whatever users you
have in mind to begin with.
And now Qasid is going
to talk a bit about a way
to think about the
development process for folks
with disabilities.
QASID SADIQ: Hey, guys.
My name is Qasid.
I work for Phil on the
Android Accessibility team.
So let's get right into it.
Now, if you really
think about it,
there are two ways that
your user can interact
with your application, right?
The first is
consuming information.
Now, this can be content
that your user wants,
or it could be indications
on how to use your UI.
And the way we
consume information
varies dramatically
from user to user.
So for example, I
consume information
by looking at what's
on screen and consuming
and processing it in that way.
A TalkBack user,
on the other hand,
will hear a
description of what's
on screen from the device's
speech synthesizer, right?
Now, once a user has
consumed and understood
that information, and they've
combined it with information
from the real
world, they can then
act on your application
to make it do things.
And just like
consuming information,
this varies
dramatically from user
to user and from
circumstances circumstance.
Now, these actions
can be something
like a tap, a swipe, a scroll.
It can be speaking
into a device.
Some Switch users even
drive the whole device
with a single button.
Now, once we combine these
two modes of interaction,
we see this cycle of action
and information, right?
And we can see that
if any part of this
is suddenly broken for
a user, our applications
become fundamentally useless.
So our goal becomes,
how do we make sure
that this is complete
for every single user?
Now, that seems like
a daunting task.
Because like we've
mentioned before,
the ways that the users
interact with our devices
actually various quite
a lot, and trying
to understand those users
is quite a complicated task.
But if you don't try to do
anything too non-standard,
and you trust us,
and you use our APIs,
then this is actually
a pretty easy task.
So I'm going to show you
some trivial things you
can do which are fundamental
and also push your accessibility
to be much better than it
otherwise would have been.
Let's start in the
ways that we break
consumption of information.
Now, for the purpose
of this, I've
created this nice little search
application-- a novel idea.
And the way that I'm indicating
that this is a search UI
is by that magnifying
glass and that little line.
Now, right away you're
going to notice something.
That's a very light shade
of gray on a very slightly
lighter shade of gray.
And that's going to be
difficult for people who--
that's going to be difficult
for a lot of people
to see because that's a
very low contrast ratio.
It's going to be frustrating
and downright impossible
for others.
So what we should do is
we should darken it up.
Just like that,
many more people are
able to use our application.
The goal here is make sure
all of your information
is visible in terms
of size and contrast.
And if you want concrete
guidelines on this,
you can go to the
Material website,
and we can give
you contrast ratios
in different circumstances
and also hard numbers in terms
of size like the 48 by 48.
Now, that was kind
of straight forward,
but there are clearly
some dramatic variations
in how we consume information.
And for those situations,
what we want you to do
is we want you to fill in the
blanks for our frameworks.
What I mean by that
is our frameworks
can infer a lot from your
view hierarchy from the code
that you've already written,
but there are some situations
where we need your help.
Let me show you.
Let's just say that
I'm a TalkBack user,
and I'm placing my
finger on screen
to hear a description of
whatever is under my finger.
And I place my finger
on the magnify icon.
Now, I want to
hear what that is.
But unfortunately, there's
no way for our frameworks
to figure out what that
means because there is
no text associated with that.
I mean, it's essentially
an arrangement
of pixels on screen.
So you guys have to fill in
the blanks as app developers,
and you can do that
by adding a label.
So in this case, I decided
to label it Search.
Make sure you keep your labels
concise and to the point.
If it's something that
indicates an action,
then make it a
simple action verb.
This is actually pretty easy.
In this situation,
all you would do
is you set the
content description.
Make sure your
string is localized
because it's a
user-facing string,
and accessibility users
don't only exist in America.
Now that our user can generally
understand what's happening
on screen, let's
make sure we don't--
let's make sure we allow
them to act on our device
appropriately or act on our
application appropriately.
So I decided to
add a new feature.
It's a Clear Text button,
so you can easily-- instead
of having to Backspace, you can
easily reset and start typing
again.
But that's a really tiny button.
You know, I'm going to
have trouble tapping that,
and someone who has some
sort of fine motor disability
is going to have a lot
more trouble tapping that.
It might just be
impossible for them.
Let's make it bigger.
And now, again, this
works for many more users.
Like Phil mentioned
earlier, make sure
your controls are simple,
and they're large.
So I decided to add
another feature.
I decided to add
a History feature.
Here you can tap
any of the queries
and see the results
of the query again.
Now, if you end up swiping
on any of these items,
you'll end up
seeing a trash icon
indicating that this item
can removed from History.
And if you continue
swiping, that item
will be removed from History.
So this is great
and all, but this
is a pretty custom-built
gesture overloaded onto an item,
and it's going to be hard
for our frameworks to detect.
So again, you guys
are going to have
to fill in the blanks
for our frameworks
and for accessibility users.
Now, you can do that
by adding an action
or an accessibility action.
And all you have to do here
is specify a user-facing label
or description of that
action-- again, a simple verb--
and the bit of code
that should be executed
when this action is performed.
Currently, you can do that with
the accessibility action API,
but we are actually
adding something
to the Android X
Library which allows
you to do this in
a single line call
with a lambda and
a string passed in.
So I've shown you
a way of thinking
about accessibility issues
and how to address them,
but you still need to know
how to find these issues
and how to verify that
you've actually fixed them.
This is where Casey comes in.
Casey?
CASEY BURKHARDT: Thanks, Qasid.
So I'm Casey Burkhardt.
I'm a software engineer
on Google's Accessibility
Engineering team, and
I lead the development
of accessibility testing
tools for Android.
So as Qasid had
pointed out, there
are many common
accessibility issues
that actually-- fixes are
fairly straightforward
from the development side
and can really improve
the accessibility of your app.
A big question,
though, is how do we
go about finding those issues?
And there are three types
of accessibility testing
today that I'd like to cover.
There's automated testing--
the use of automated tools;
manual testing, where you
use Android's accessibility
services yourself to understand
the user's experience;
and finally user testing,
where you would actually
bring in users with
various disabilities
and truly get their feedback
and understand their experience
using your application.
My section of the talk
focuses mainly on automation
because right now we see
that as one big area where
we can make vast improvements
across the ecosystem
if we have some developers'
cooperation using these tools.
So automated accessibility
testing until several years
ago on Android
didn't really exist.
In around 2015, we
launched a project
known as Android's Accessibility
Test Framework, which
is an Android and Java library
that essentially houses
a lot of detection logic for
the more common accessibility
issues that we can
identify within an app's
UI in a rule-based fashion.
This is an open source project,
so you can go and find it
on GitHub.
And essentially, what
it's aiming to do
is look at your
app's UI at runtime
and find some more of the
automatable, mechanical aspects
of accessibility that
we see day to day
that affect users the most.
So we can find a lot
of the common issues
that Qasid discussed,
so we can tell you
if you have a control
within your UI
that is missing a label
for a screen reader.
We can identify low
contrast text and images.
We can tell you if you've got
clickable items within a UI
that that fail to meet our
minimums for touch target
guidelines.
And we also identify a
number of various other
implementation-specific issues.
And the core testing
library, ATF,
is growing constantly to
find more new and interesting
issues.
We've taken this library,
and we've integrated it
with common developer
endpoints-- essentially,
tools that you'll use commonly
throughout the development
lifecycle and you can leverage
throughout your project.
I want to talk through some
of those integrations today
and how you can use them and
get started with them quickly.
So first and foremost,
we've got integrations
with two test frameworks
that are pretty commonly used
throughout unit and UI
tests on Android apps.
The first is
Espresso Robolectric.
So essentially the idea with
these integrations of ATF
is they will piggyback on
top of your existing tests.
So you have a test that
runs, loads some UI
from your application,
interacts with that UI,
and asserts some state.
During the interaction
phase of your test,
if you've enabled our
integrations with Espresso
or Robolectric, we'll actually
evaluate the UI at the time
that it's interacted with.
So if we identify an
accessibility issue
that we believe will affect
a user with a disability's
ability to interact
with your application,
we will fail your existing test.
So if you already have
strong test coverage
with either Robolectric
or Espresso,
enabling ATF's integration
with that test framework
might be a great way to get
a decent amount of coverage
for automation in terms
of accessibility testing
throughout your app.
A few other points
to note here--
each framework
offers what's known
as an AccessibilityValidator.
And this is an
object that you can
use to essentially configure ATF
behavior inside of your tests.
So you can configure ATF, for
example, to not fail your test
and just log something if
we've run into an issue.
You can set up ATF to crawl from
the root of your view hierarchy
whenever you perform an action
rather than just evaluating
the item that was
interacted with.
It's a great way to get
some additional coverage.
And you can even use
AccessibilityValidator
to set a whitelist.
So if you want to turn
on accessibility tests
within your Robolectric
or Espresso tests,
you can do so, maintain
a green presubmit,
and burn through issues
that you know about
by creating and registering one
of these whitelists for known
issues.
So specifically inside how you
leverage these between Espresso
and Robolectric, in Espresso
you're going to essentially
call
AccessibilityChecks.enable()
from within your tests setup.
This is going to essentially
trigger our global assertion
to run whenever you use a view
action within an Espresso test.
So in this case, the
view action is run.
We'll perform an evaluation on
the view that was interacted
with and its subtree.
AccessibilityValidator is
actually returned by the call
to AccessibilityChecks.enable().
So if you need to further
customize ATF's behavior,
you can do so from the object
returned from that call.
Within Robolectric,
it's slightly different.
So instead of calling
AccessibilityChecks.enable(),
AccessibilityChecks
is an annotation,
and you'll annotate your test
method or class that you'd like
to enable accessibility
checking within.
And it relies on you using
ShadowView.clickOn to actually
interact with
elements in your UI
through your Robolectric. tests.
So avoid the temptation to use
viewperformClick() directly.
The AccessibilityValidator
functionality's
available in Robolectric
through a different class
that mirrors the same API.
You can just look
for AccessibilityUtil
and make static calls there
to configure ATF's behavior.
So in addition to integrations
with these automated test
frameworks, we've built a
separate standalone tool
known as Accessibility Scanner.
This is a direct
integration of ATF,
but Accessibility Scanner acts
as a front end for the library.
It will evaluate the foreground
UI of your application
at runtime on an
actual Android device.
The way it works
is essentially you
install Accessibility Scanner.
You turn it on.
It will add a floating
button globally
to the device's screen.
You'll open up your
application, navigate to the UI
that you'd like to evaluate,
and just tap the button.
And what you see is
essentially a report
that describes the ways
in which you can improve
that UI for accessibility.
Again, these will mirror
the same types of issues
that ATF, and Espresso,
and Robolectric
can identify as well.
It's very easy to
take these reports
from Accessibility Scanner
and share them with your team.
You can currently export
to email or Drive.
And it doesn't really
require technical skills.
You don't have to have a debug
version of your application
or a user debug device.
You don't need to do anything
special to set this up.
It works on any app on
any Android device running
Marshmallow or later.
And really, you don't even have
to have a lot of experience
related to accessibility.
Each issue that Accessibility
Scanner can identify
comes with extensive
documentation that gives you
background on how that
issue might affect users
and how to think
about that issue
during the design,
development, and test
phases of your project.
So please do download
Accessibility Scanner.
It's something I
highly recommend
we use when we build UI.
G.co/AccessibilityScanner will
take you to the Play Store
page.
Finally, one last integration
I'd like to cover today,
and this is a new one.
We've launched it
a few months ago.
It's an integration of
our Accessibility Testing
Framework and the Play Store
Developer Consoles Pre-Launch
Report.
For those of you who haven't
used Pre-Launch Report yet,
it is a great tool to get a
sanity check during the launch
process, the release process
for an APK to the Play Store,
either on an open
or a closed channel.
Essentially, the way it
works is you upload an APK.
Pre-Launch Report will take
that APK, instrument it,
and push it to a number of
different physical devices
in a lab.
And we'll crawl your
app, essentially,
on these different
devices and generate
reports that include findings
about performance, security,
and now accessibility as well.
So ATF is running
alongside Pre-Launch Report
as it's crawling application,
and it's generating reports
at each stage in the crawl.
And it's taking
all of the results
and de-duplicating them.
So if you'd like
to check this out,
it's available now in Play
Store Developer Console
under Release Management.
And you should be able to
see accessibility results
for any APK that you've
uploaded to the Store
since fairly early in July.
So please do check that out.
And here's what it looks like,
just to give you an idea.
Here this-- the main
entry point for an APK
will show you all different
categories of issues
that we've identified.
It will show you
clusters of issues.
And you can click
on any one of those,
and it will show
you more details
about the specific problem.
So in this case, we're
pointing out an issue
relating to touch target size.
And in the column
on the left, you
see many different examples of
that same de-duplicated issue
across different crawls
of your application
that Pre-Launch
Report has performed.
You have access to the same
additional documentation
here as well too.
So if you're not familiar
with a particular issue,
the Learn More
link will give you
the details you need to resolve
it regardless of what stage
your project is currently in.
So I want to wrap up by talking
about an accessibility testing
strategy.
We talked a lot
about automation,
but we didn't go into too
much detail on the other two--
manual testing and user testing.
And these are equally important.
Automation is great
because it helps
you find issues very quickly
early in the development cycle,
especially if you have good
test coverage with our automated
tools.
So essentially, think
about automation
as a way to catch very
common issues quickly
but not as a way to guarantee
that your app or your UI
is fully accessible.
To really understand
your user's experience,
to get that awareness of how
your UI is actually performing
with an accessibility
service, we really
highly recommend you go and
actually turn on TalkBack.
Turn on Switch Access.
Try them out.
Learn how to use them and
gain a true understanding
of your user's experience.
The way I like to
describe it is automation
is capable of finding a missing
label for a screen reader,
but we can't really tell you
if your labels make sense.
So really only by
understanding, putting yourself
in the user's shoes
and understanding
their experience-- or
asking users directly about
their experience--
only then can you truly
understand how accessible
your UI is for users with
various different disabilities.
And we have found
at Google, both
looking at our first-party
and third-party applications,
the most successful, the most
highly accessible apps that we
see day to day are
the apps that combine
multiple accessibility
testing strategies.
So those that
leverage automation
during presubmit or continuous
integration, but also
have a regular process for
manual accessibility testing
or bringing users in and
understanding their perspective
on the accessibility
of an application.
So these are all
things to consider.
With that, I'll hand
it back to Qasid,
who's going to talk to us more
about some of the newer APIs
for expressing app semantics.
QASID SADIQ: Hey, guys.
I'm back.
So let's just say that you've
adopted the APIs that I've
talked about earlier, and
you've adopted the testing
that Casey has suggested.
And at this point, you've
got a pretty good foundation
of accessibility in
your application.
But the more you're
testing, the more
you realize that there's some
holes in your experience,
and that's breaking that
cycle of interaction
that I mentioned earlier.
So we've been adding new API
and new things to make it
so these holes get plugged.
So the first things
first is clickable spans,
those a little
clickable bits of text.
Before API 26, non-URL
spans were fundamentally
inaccessible, and
developers had to write
a bunch of hacky workarounds
to make these things work.
That's now changed.
In addition to that, in the
latest alpha of the Android X
library, we've added
API to make this work
all the way back to API 19.
So you can look
out for that too.
Secondly, there's some
views that, as far as a user
is concerned, act and
behave like Windows.
They have their own special
content, their own lifecycle,
so on and so forth.
And we call those
accessibility panes.
Now, you as the developer
need to inform our frameworks
to present these a little
bit differently to the user.
And the way you do that is
by passing a non-null string
to setAccessibilityPaneTitle
on the view.
And again, this is a
user-facing string, so make sure
it's concise, and
it's localized.
This is available in
API 28, but we've also
added this API to ViewCompat
in the latest Android X alpha,
and that'll work all
the way back to API 19.
And finally, there are headings.
These section titles are
used by TalkBack users,
for example, to navigate through
sections quickly and easily.
And the way you specify that
is exactly what you probably
expect.
Pass in a Boolean to
setAccessibilityHeading
on a view.
This is also available
in 28, and we added this
to the latest alpha of
the Android X library.
That'll work all
the way back to 19.
[INAUDIBLE],, thank
you for your time.
Now it's back to Phil.
PHIL WEAVER: All right.
So circling back to
the title of this,
which was Making
Accessibility Easy,
we really want this to be easy.
It's the only way that
users with disabilities
are really going to be able
to access the ecosystem.
Because occasionally
we'll counter somebody
who's really willing
to do the extra mile,
really dig into their
app and sort out
all of the issues
for accessibility,
and that's great.
But not everybody, not every
developer can possibly do that.
And so we need to make
this as easy as possible
so that everyone can build this
into their workflow in a really
natural way.
And so certainly
to get the basics,
we want it to be
straightforward.
So if you've got
reasonable contrast
to make the information
visible to everyone,
you've got simple big
controls, you're using labels,
we really want that to kind
of get you almost all the way.
And then some of these other
APIs like Qasid was just
describing should be able
to handle some of these more
specialized situations.
Like if you've got a full
screen fragment transition,
you use the pane
title to make sure
that that gets handled the same
way a window transition would.
So saying that we
want it to be easy--
it means if it's
hard, we've messed up,
and we should fix that.
We've found some developers
will really like-- well,
the framework seems to
be coming up short here.
So I'm going to
engineer a workaround
to get around the problems
with the framework.
Honestly, please don't do that.
Let us fix it because
we can fix it at scale,
and only we can fix it.
It needs to be fixed
inside Android.
If you find it in Android X,
if you want to fix it, by all
means upload it to
Android X. And we're
happy to accept fixes.
But we want it
fixed centrally so
that we can get a
consistent experience
throughout the whole ecosystem.
If you are engineering
some super custom solution,
you think-- you know--
is an engineer working
at a different company going
to actually do this work?
And if the answer
is no, then there's
probably something wrong.
And so please reach out
if we're messing this up.
You can file bugs on AOSP.
You can ask questions
on Stack Overflow.
But we much prefer to--
we really prefer to get
the feedback that something
is difficult, so we can try
to find an elegant solution
that everyone can use.
We want the-- some of things
that Qasid just presented,
before he did that work,
the effort required
to do some of these
things really required
learning a new API surface.
And we really wanted to condense
everything we could down to one
line.
And so we're trying to
present solutions that really
aren't-- like if you've got this
thing, here's one line of code.
It's all you need.
If you get to
something that seems
like it should be one line
of code, and it's not,
let us know.
And another place to go
just for other resources is
g.co/androidaccessibility.
There's a link here to
the developer.android.com
for accessibility
testing, the link
to get to the
Accessibility Scanner,
and also the test framework
project that Casey described.
That's available
open source on GitHub
if you're interested
to look at that.
So really appreciate
your time, and we'd
be very happy
especially-- if you've
got feedback for us of other
things that should be easier
than they are,
we're going to also
be out at the office hours
for a while this afternoon.
We'd really love to talk to you.
So thanks a lot for coming
and for your efforts
in helping to make a
consistent ecosystem of very
accessible apps.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]